Wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rettimbe, wo, Rett Einen wunderschönen guten Abend, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe, die anscheinend nicht sehr weihnachtlich angestrichen ist. Also ich habe einen Hut auf, ich habe warme Pantoffeln an. Ich verstehe nicht, warum du das Intro halt nicht für Weihnachten dann dir aufhebst. Das haust du ja jetzt im November raus. Weihnachten ist uninteressant, das schönste ist doch die Vorfreude, wo du einfach gar nicht mehr erwarten kannst. Jetzt kommen bald die ersten Adventskänder raus, die beste Erfindung aller Zeiten, die Vorfreude, aber natürlich befinde ich mich in einem harten Klammergriff der Gemütlichkeit von Stefan Tietze, eine Umarmung, die mittlerweile seit zehn Jahren anhält und ich genieße sie mit jedem Tag mehr. Ja, mit jedem Tag wird mir klar, dass es eine Art Bearhug ist, eine feindliche Übernahme. Die Rippen brechen einzeln Stück für Stück weg wie ein Klavier, in der Klaviersonate unter Stephans harter Hand. Denn wie jeder weiß, Klaviersonaten brechen weg. Das ist die perfekte Metapher. Ich begrüße, gegenüber von mir sitzt Florian Will, heute an der langen Leine. Okay, wunderbar. Du hast mich heute mal ein bisschen rausgelassen. Mir gegenüber sitzt Stephan der Presslufthammer Tiese. Er hat mich vor der Aufnahme explizit gebeten, darauf hinzuweisen, ihn so zu nennen, wegen seiner neu gestarteten Boxkarriere. Er ist jetzt der Boxer und sein Markenzeichen ist der Presslufthammer, den er mit in den Ring nimmt. Natürlich eine Metapher. Der grosse Presslufthammer für das männliche Geschlechtsteil. Gut, du nimmst ihn immer mit in den Ring, wirbelst damit herum, sagst dich, ich hämmer euch alle in Grund und Boden und verlierst dann relativ schnell. Das ist ein Wort, was Mikrofone besonders mögen. Prop. Das Mikrofon sitzt nur so da und sagt, bitte lass dir nicht über Props reden. Bitte nicht über Props, keine Props und Preppies. Keine Props, keine Preppies, keine, ja. Ich habe letztens nochmal Pump and Circumstance gehört. Don't even. Pump and Preppies wollen wir. Damit haben wir heute nichts zu tun. Womit wir zu tun haben, sind natürlich Caro und Toni, die dieses herrliche Intro zusammengetragen haben. In emsiger Kleinstarbeit haben sie jede kleine Audiowelle zusammengetragen. Und das ganze Jahr wie Eichhörnchen haben sie jeden Tag ein kleines bisschen was gefunden und in ihren Beutelchen gesteckt. Daher hat sich das perfekte Gehör ab, sodass alles richtig gesungen wurde. Im klarsten Fistur. Ach, herrlich. Es ist in der Klarheit wirklich perfekt getroffen. Florentinwell, Florentinwell! Also wirklich so genailtes Fistur. Florentinwell! eine Wohlfühl-Tonart auf jeden Fall. Oh, die schönste. Es ist eine der schönsten Tonarten. Es gibt aber auch schlimme. Ich habe tatsächlich diese Woche ein bisschen über das Festnetz nachgedacht. Und ich habe gemerkt, was für eine vergangene, untergegangene Welt das alles ist. Wieso hast du darüber nachgedacht? Also diese Woche voll Disclaimer,
ihr wisst nicht, wann wir gerade aufnehmen, aber in dieser Woche ist viel passiert. Ja.
Da lässt es mich schon Wunder nehmen, ich war in der
Schweiz, wie du merkst, es nimmt mich Wunder,
wieso du ausgerechnet über
Festnetz nachgedacht hast. Auch bei mir ist viel passiert,
denn ich war beim
Bäcker. Im Privaten.
Also während die Welt ist sich am
Abgrund befindlich im Flur und ich habe mit seinem kleinen privaten Problem zu tun und ich finde das toll. Ja, na klar, ich war beim Bäcker, aber nicht wie du denkst, jetzt Montag bis Samstag, nein, nein, nein, ich war zu diesen herrlichen, ja, Unzeiten, die quasi ausserhalb des Raumzeitkontinuums stehen, die ganze Welt steht still, doch irgendwo brennt ein kleines Lichtlein noch, und zwar die Bäckereien am Sonntag. Könnte ein schöner Fotoband eigentlich sein. In ganz Deutschland gibt es diese kleinen Bäckereien, ich rede jetzt von Bäckereien in Supermärkten, wo der gesamte Supermarkt stockdunkel ist, wirklich die Dementoren gehen umher, der Supermarkt komplett abgeriegelt, das komplette Eis schmilzt vor sich hin, man denkt sich, es gibt's Gesetz, könnte ich da jetzt einfach rein und mir Kitterkets holen ohne Ende, niemand hält mich davon ab, außer diese beiden roten Augen, die blitzen hinten von der Fleischtheke, denen ich nicht zu nahe kommen möchte, eine gespenstische Stimmung und bei meinem üblichen Supermarkt, da wird das dann immer so abgehängt. Keine kleine Zwischenfrage muss erlaubt sein, ist es der Supermarkt, der Bäcker, wo du deine Probleme hast, deine Bools und deine Weltmeisterbräutchen? Nein, tatsächlich nicht. Du hast ihn gewechselt. Nein, es gibt einen Bäcker in der Nähe des Arbeitsplatzes und einen Bäcker in der Nähe des Heimatortes. Ich bin deine Arbeit. Du bist ein Lifetime-Projekt von mir, an dem ich arbeite jeden Tag. Ich meisle jeden Tag, aber trotzdem habe ich noch andere Arbeiten neben dir, muss man tatsächlich sagen. Und da war alles abgehängt tatsächlich, also es gibt einen anderen Eingang in diesen Supermarkt, nicht den Haupteingang, der bleibt still an dem Sonntag. Das sind doch die besten Dinge, da hast du das Gefühl, das ist meine Welt. Also ich habe auch so ein Tor in meiner Nachbarschaft, da habe ich den Code so erzählt und das ist wie so fast travel im Spiel. Ja, so es gibt, wenn man den Level schon gemacht hat, dann kommt man schneller durch, so mit dieser Flöte, der Zauberflöte. Also du irgendwann, wenn du, Spiel ist ja so lange ein Tutorial, bis du die fast travel Funktion hast, wo das Spiel dich, das ist wirklich der rote Faden dieser Sendung, die lange Leine, du kannst machen, was du willst, du kannst machen, was ist plötzlich deine Welt, du hast sie zu eigen gemacht. Und sowas finde ich ganz toll, wenn du dir so einen Hintereingang erschließt von etwas. Wie cool ist das denn? Wo normalerweise nur Mitarbeiter durchgehen dürfen, nur heute sagt man immer so, hey, da darf ich doch gar nicht. Komm mal hier rein, komm mal da durch. Und dann ist man da und steht an mit diesen ganzen anderen Leuten, die da irgendwie mitten im Schneegestöber sitzen. Das macht das weniger besonders, weil die auch alle durch die Tür gegangen sind. Ja gut, das stimmt natürlich, aber es ist so eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft. So irgendwie, man sitzt da zusammen, kriege ich noch was, kriege ich noch Brot, gibt es noch Brot für mich oder müssen meine Kinder wieder hungern heute? Und dann plötzlich durch diese gespenstische, aber doch wohlige Stimmung reißt plötzlich ein der schrecklichste Klingelton der Welt. Dieser Praxisklingelton. Dieser Praxisklingelton, wo ich wirklich mich frage, wer hat den ersonnen, zu welchem Zweck? Den hatte mal jemand, ein Freund von mir zu Hause. Ganz furchtbar. Und es gibt Leute, die haben zu Hause den Praxisklingelton gehabt. Und ich bin froh, dass das ganze Thema komplett ad acta gelegt wurde, Festnetz. Furchtbar. Aber das ist ja irre. Also wirklich diese armen Menschen, die in Praxen, in Behörden oder hier beim Bäcker arbeiten müssen, wo jede Sekunde, ja wirklich jede Sekunde aus dem Nichts ein eine garstige Melodie, Ja.lich, erdacht von Satan persönlich auf seiner goldenen Violine, wo kommt das her?
Also wenn jemand sagt so, gib mir mal eine Melodie für so einen Klingelton, irgendwie was einfach so, ey hier ist ein Anruf, falls du Lust hast, kannst du reden.
Aha.
Ja.
Gibt's noch andere Ideen?
Mhm.
Da hinten, Carlo?
Ich hätte noch folgende.
Ja.
Okay.
Aber sein Vater war Satan persönlich und hat dann diesen Klingelton durchgeboxt. Es ist so schrecklich. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das Musikwissenschaftler überhaupt greifen können. Also kann man das in Notation schreiben? Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, das irgendwie einzufangen? Ja, so John Cage-mäßig, einfach Lärm, Noise. Es ist einfach Noise. Es ist wirklich so schrecklich. Gegen welche Ideen hat das gewonnen? In irgendeinemonnen? Vor allem ist das alles der gleiche Hersteller von diesem Telefon? Wo kommt das her? Wer hat das sich ausgedacht? Ganz, ganz schrecklich. Ja, und ich finde gut, bei iPhones hat man sich ja auf die Marimba, das Marimba-Phone geeinigt. Ja, aber das perfekte Instrument. Perfektes Instrument. Ich glaube, du kannst gar nicht nerven auf einem Marimba-Phone. Das ist gar nicht möglich. So klar, du kannst schlecht spielen, gut spielen, aber es ist nicht so, ich will das Kind von nebenan umbringen, weil es auf der Trompete fliegt. Es hat natürlich nur Vorteile, ausser für Leute, die Marimba spielen. Die werden nämlich immer gefragt, kannst du deine Marimba mitbringen? Und er so, nein, ich will auch mal mit Frauen sprechen. Ich kann nicht immer nur meine Marimba mitbringen. Ihr wollt wieder die iPhone-Klingeltöne alle hören. Na, das stimmt doch nicht, du hast doch ein großes Repertoire. Ja, eben, aber ihr fragt immer nur nach den scheiß iPhone-Klingeltönen. Naja, gut, ich meine, Olli Welke muss auch immer seine grössten Hits machen, wenn er irgendwo eingeladen ist. Was für Olli Welke? Naja, halt nochmal. Sagt die Gensy, was für Olli Welke, hä, Digga, was für Olli Welke? Vielleicht meinte ich auch Olli Dittrich. Ja, was für Olli Dittrich. Nee, wer ist das mit Palim Palim? Ja. Wiegald Boning. Nee, Palim Palim, oh Gott, nee. Bernhard Hohecker, Entschuldigung. Du gehst alle kleinen, glanzköpfigen Comedians durch. Sag noch mal eine Tübe Pommes oder so. So, dann musst du das auch mal machen. Der von Honig im Kopf ist der mit Palim Palim. Das ist Til Schweiger. Das ist der von Manta Manta. Das ist ja was ganz anderes. Aber der musst du auch mal machen. Und mit dem Marimperfon hast du auch nochmal ähm, kannst du einmal noch einmal noch den und alles so automatisch. Entschuldigung, können wir kurz die Musik anhalten? Ich spiele das gerade. Ach so, sorry, es ist so tief eingebracht. Der ganze Freundeskreis sitzt hier. Wer soll euch anrufen? Naja, es gibt dann doch einen. Hört auf, ich spiele das doch. Ihr seht doch, dass ich spiele. Aber ich bemitleide wirklich alle Menschen, die auf der Arbeit diesen Klingelton, diesen Festnetz-Klingelton eingebrannt haben und den dann zum Beispiel beim Bäcker hören. Du stehst sonntags beim Bäcker, freust dich auf deinen mit Marmelade an einer Stelle komplett vollgestopften Berliner Weltmeisterbrötchen Rockenleib Urkrüstchen und dann wirst du plötzlich rausgerissen und denkst an deinen Zahnarztjob, den du vor drei Jahren schon aufgegeben hast wegen dieses schrecklichen Klingeltons, ganz furchtbar. Wohingegen Bäcker an einem Sonntag, die eine eigenständige Bäckerpraxis haben, ein bisschen trist und traurig wirken. Also ich verstehe diese Romantik, in ein grosses Laden reinzukommen, nur wegen des Bäckers, der Auffahrt der Supermarkt nicht auf, finde ich super, aber so ein eigenständiger Bäcker reicht immer ein bisschen ein bisschen traurig. Und ich höre jeden Sonderer den Satz, nee, nur noch, was Sie hier sehen. Auf meine Frage, gibt's noch die Handbrötchen? Nein, nur noch, was Sie hier sehen. Nur noch, was Sie hier sehen. Was Sie hier sehen, ja. Und das ist interessant. Weil das ist ein Satz, der in unserer Welt, in der wir leben, ist selten nur noch das, was man sieht. Wir leben in einer Welt von Überkonsum, von ständiger Verfügbarkeit und da einfach mal auch Bescheidenheit.
Nein, sie können sich jetzt unterscheiden zwischen den zwei Vitalkaspern und den drei Uhrknoten.
Genau.
Und das ist alles, was noch da ist.
Und die Auswahl ist so ein bisschen wie Omas Süßigkeiten-Schrank.
Es gibt drei Sachen und zwei davon sind mit Minze.
Und ich will nicht, dass Minze was zu tun hat mit meinem herzhaften salzigen Frühstück. Will ich die Wärters Original oder will ich noch die Zimtstangen aus der Hitlerjugend von früher oder was soll's werden? Ganz furchtbar. Und warum riecht der Laden nach meiner Oma? Ich war irgendwann so verzweifelt, dass ich angefangen habe, Kaffeebohnen zu essen oder Zuckerstückchen. Das einzige, was ich bei Oma gefunden habe. Ja, Hauptsache irgendwas Essen, das ist schon irre. Rein essen. Ich habe natürlich auch mal Kaffeefilter probiert, weil die aussehen wie Waffeln. Anderes Thema.
Ich habe tatsächlich schon mal
Die sehen wirklich ein bisschen aus.
Es sieht schon lecker aus.
Ja, wie dieses Dropwaffen.
Die sind ganz dünn, diese
perforierten.
Ich war tatsächlich schon mal in einem Supermarkt eingekauft,
als er geschlossen war. Was, glaube ich,
eines meiner transzendentesten
Erlebnisse 2022 war, glaube ich, unter den 10. Seitdem lebst du in einer Anderswelt. Ich lebe in einer Anderswelt. Ich weiß nicht mehr, in welcher Welt ich bin. Wenn du einmal den Schleier durchschritten hast, viele Leute denken ja, ich will den Schleier durchschreiten, meditieren, beten, nehmen Drogen, reisen nach Indien, wollen den Schleier durchschreiten. Nein, nein, nein, kauft im Supermarkt, der zu ist. Ja, aber seid euch auch gewahr, wenn ihr einmal den Schleier durchschritten habt, dann wisst ihr nie wieder, auf welcher Seite ihr seid. Seid euch generell immer mehr gewahr. Gut, du bist dir jeden Tag sicher, auf welcher Seite des Schleiers du stehst. Stefan Tietze wacht auf und ist sich hundertprozentig sicher, ich bin im Diesseits. Ja. So, ich nicht mehr. Ich hab immer dieses, ist da nicht ein Doch jenseits, wo bin ich, weiß ich nicht mehr genau. Und das war, das war krass. Und zwar, ich feiere jedes Jahr Campen mit meinen Freunden im Sommer. Und da gibt es einen kleinen Dorf Edeka, ja, kleiner, verträumter Dorf Edeka. Der schon kennt, die Bierjungs. Die Bierjungs, ja, der uns natürlich kennt und jedes Jahr und die haben uns jetzt auch schon aufwachsen sehen, irgendwie als wir da mit 15 das erste Mal waren und alles. Und da ist natürlich dann auch immer so das Ding, ja, wir sind am Campingplatz, haben keine Versorgung, haben vielleicht auch noch nicht immer einen Kühlschrank gehabt. Und dann ist immer so, ja, Sonntag, wir haben Hunger, so, was sollen wir essen? Und dann war es tatsächlich mal so, dass wir da mal angerufen haben, so, ja, wie sieht es denn aus? Heute ist zwar Sonntag, aber wir brauchen noch was. Diese Dreistigkeit. Ich hab schon Angst, bei der Pizzeria anzurufen, die Aufhand und zu bestellen, was auf der Karte ist und zu fragen, ob sie zu mir liefern, was sie tun. Das ist alles schon... Was sie von sich aus anbieten, für einen Aufpreis. Was ihr Job ist, was sie haben das aufgemacht, damit das passiert. Und davor hab ich schon Angst. Das ist so aus meiner Komfortzone heraus, bei dem Supermarkt anzurufen. Ich habe diesen Anruf auch nicht getätigt, da kannst du dir sicher sein. Aber wer ist der Mann, der das getan hat? Gut, da möchte ich jetzt nicht zu intim werden. Doch. Aber am Ende war das tatsächlich dann möglich. Und dann war man tatsächlich, dann hat die uns reingelassen, die wohnt auch da bei den Laden direkt, so die Besitzerin oder da irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Und dann hat die uns einfach aufgemacht und dann waren wir da
drin. Und es war ganz
interessant, weil man stellt sich ja schon immer die Frage,
genauso wie, was machen Haustiere,
während die Besitzer nicht da ist, wie sieht ein
Supermarkt aus, wenn es geschlossen ist? Also
ist die Kühlung noch an? Genau.
Was ist mit dem Nogga?
Also ist der auch noch
eiskalt? Warten die und oder schmelzen die einmal und frieren? Die Noggas werden doch zuerst abgestellt, das kann man keiner erzählen. Das ist die erste Kühlung, die ausgeht. Nogga, danach Schoko-Fresh. Naja, es kann ja sein, dass die einmal über die Nacht komplett schmelzen und dann morgens wieder gefrieren und man es aber nicht merkt. So, weil es einfach einmal den Aggregatzustand wieder wechselt. Weil ihr Schlaf ist auch eine Art von Schlafen dann fürs Eis. Und stellst dich heraus, nein, die Kühlung ist noch an, aber es liegen überall so komische Decken drauf. Was? Also so in den Kühlregalen, da sind dann so Staubdecken, wie so Schränke. Panikdecken. Weil normalerweise sind ja die Kühlregale offen, damit man die Produkte herausnehmen kann. Nicht alle, nicht alle. Das habe ich auch noch bis heute nicht ganz verstanden. Es gibt die offenen und es gibt die zuen und es gibt die richtig zuen. Ein Beispiel für richtig zu, Eistruhen. Das ist Hochsicherheits. Also ich glaube, wenn die Nogger frech waren, dann kommen sie schön hoch sicherheitsgefängnis und dann erstmal auch unten.
Also ich verstehe, es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen, weil ich merke schon die Kommentare jetzt reinkommen in Echtzeit, es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen Gefriertruhe und Kühlung. Also so Käse ist eine Kühlung. Sehr gut. So, ich weiss ich wohl.
Aber es gibt auch den Lachs zum Beispiel, der ist gefroren.
Aber den hole ich nicht aus einer Tiefkühltruhe, sondern aus so recht leicht öffenbaren Türen. Und das verstehe ich nicht. Oder bilde ich mir jetzt gerade ein, dass das gar nicht existiert. Es gibt, glaube ich, auch Gefrierschränke, wo dann alles rausfällt, wo dann die kalte Luft so rausfällt, auf einen drauf, kann einen manchmal niederdrücken. Aber es ist dann diese offene,
also wir reden jetzt mal von der Milchschnitte.
Milchschnitte im Kühlregal,
offen, lach dich an,
du siehst es, du greifst rein,
es ist alles schön. Aber wenn
der Supermarkt zu ist, dann werden die tatsächlich
zugemacht, damit die Kühlung
dann nicht, weil die wahrscheinlich
ziemlich ineffizient ist, wenn es offen ist,
und damit du über Nacht dann Strom sparst, müssen
die alle Kühlungen mit so
Schränken, Schranktüren zumachen.
Und da war ich dann da
und dann war es so, wo ist jetzt
alles? Du bist völlig desorientiert, du bist
stockdunkel, dein Geruchssinn verlässlich,
du bist wirklich in einer Anderswelt, du bist
durch den Schleier geschnitten. Das ist also lustig, wenn so kleine Elfen herumlaufen.
Und wenn sie
gesehen werden, sterben sie aber. Oh. Wie Einzelmännchen. Die hören auf, also die machen nachts die Jobs der Kölner, aber wenn die gesehen werden, dann lösen sie sich auf. Aber machen die nicht immer extra diese kleinen Filmchen für die Zuschauer, dass die gesehen werden? Das sind die Meinzelmännchen, die gibt's auch. Ach so, die werden gesehen. Guten Abend! Genau, guten Abend. Die wollen gesehen werden, bei denen ist es anders. Ja, guten Abend. Ja, sie soll sich immer so schreien. Bei den Meinzelmännchen ist es wahrscheinlich anders, wenn die eine Zeit lang nicht gesehen werden, dann verschwinden sie. Die müssen um Aufmerksamkeit kämpfen. Das ZDF verschwindet, wenn es nicht mehr gesehen wird. Richtig. Wohingegen die Heinzelmännchen, die aus Köln, Heinzelmännchenbrunn, können Sie sich angucken, sind die stillen Helferlein, die nachts den Job machen, wenn man sie aber sieht, hören sie auf, lösen sich auf, sterben, wir wissen nicht genau, was passiert. Wie so Kugelfische. Ist natürlich eine ganz schreckliche Geschichte, wenn die zusammenleben, weil die Meinzelmännchen wollen gesehen werden, wollen sehen und müssen dann aber die Heinzelmännchen opfern quasi, weil die ja, wenn sie einmal gesehen haben, tot sind. Das ist eine schöne Fabel, finde ich.
Mhm, meins bleibt meins und in Köln sagt man, it is wie it is. Ich glaube, auf eine Art bleibt dann auch alles wieder, wie es war. Aber sehr spannend, ich wäre gerne mal bei einem Bäcker im Supermarkt, der zu ist, oder ich würde auch gerne mal im Supermarkt einkaufen, der zu ist. Ich finde das eine tolle Veranstaltung. Es ist wirklich toll, es ist wirklich schön. Sollte man generell auch mal machen, so Tag der offenen, also es gibt ja in Köln manchmal oder in anderen Städten auch die lange Nacht der Museen, die immer sehr voll ist, was mich immer irritiert, wo man denkt so, ja, das Museum ist die ganze Woche leer, geht da einfach hin und dann stellen sich alle in die Kälte im November und stehen zwei Stunden fürs Museum an, in das sie nicht gehen, aber einfach, weil es das Event ist und nachts im Museum vielleicht auch dazu beigetragen hat. Aber so, man will einfach an einem anderen Zeitpunkt, will ich jetzt da rein. Ja. Ich will da jetzt rein. Und das finde ich sehr spannend, weil natürlich macht das was mit dir. Und das würde ich aber auch gerne mit anderen Orten haben. Nachts in den Supermarkt. Die lange Nacht der Supermärkte, die lange Nacht der Büchereien, die lange Nacht der Fabriken. Letzten Endes ist es ja einfach nur der kindliche Wunsch, noch länger wach zu bleiben. Das ist ja der gleiche, also gerade heute, ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob das für Kinder heutzutage noch die gleiche Romantik hat, weil früher liefen ja andere Filme dann nachts im Linean, heute schaust du Netflix, ob 14 Uhr oder 23 Uhr ist das gleiche, aber du willst halt trotzdem noch wach bleiben, obwohl es aus Elternperspektive, ja, sei doch froh, dass du im Bett bist, du kannst einfach morgen weiter gucken, aber es ist so dieser Zwang, irgendwas zu machen, wo man nicht mehr darf. Und Amazon macht nicht zu, ne. Sehr schön, sehr schön. Amazon schliesst nicht.
Sehr schön. Amazon ist offen. Es ist aber auch so ein bisschen dieser Idee.
Bei Amazon brennt immer Licht.
Die neue Trilogie.
Amazon schläft nicht,
Amazon macht nie zu, bei Amazon brennt immer
Licht. Der Dreiteiler, wo du Stück für Stück
Amazon den Konzern auseinander nimmst
und dann aber auch wieder aufbaust. Genau, ich halte
dir die Maske vor und reisse dir den Spiegel ab. Der Enthüllungsroman. Ich reiße dir in den Spiegel vom Gesicht. Du hast dich ja verkaufen lassen, das war dein Selbstexperiment. Du hast dich als Ware selbst reingestellt bei Amazon, das war so ein Medienstunt, auch zum Vertrieb. Ich war in der Schweiz im Kunsthaus und da war die Abramowitsch-Ausstellung.
Und sie hatte ein ähnliches, also
bekannte serbische Künstlerin,
macht viel so Happenings,
also Aktionskunst. Und sie hat
nämlich auch ja dieses Kunstwerk gemacht, wo
sie sich
sozusagen zum Objekt gemacht hat.
Und dann war da ein Tisch mit
ganz vielen Möglichkeiten. Also
es gab Messer, es gab aber auch Weintrauben, es gab sämtliche seltsame Gegenstände und man konnte machen mit ihr, was man wollte, war so die Aufgabe. Das war wirklich sehr gruselig und das habe ich auch gemacht quasi, also ich habe es geklaut und habe mich bei Amazon verkaufen lassen. Moment, aber du warst auch bei diesem Happening? Sie war nie, das wurde nicht reenacted. Aha, also es war dann nur Tisch mit... Ich hab mich dann da hingeschniet und ein Angebot gemacht in den Raum, weil ich dachte, na ja... Du hast aber auf die Weintrauben so im Kopf geschält. Ich dachte, die sehen ja schon lecker aus. Aber es haben alle nur ein Mann gesagt, stehn Sie auf bitte. Oh, ist das Kunst? Also ist das Kunst für dich jetzt?
Was?
Du hast ja eine Reaktion hervorgerufen.
Der Mann, der hat ja anscheinend dich nicht als Kunst wahrgenommen und hat gesagt, das ist nicht Kunst, steh auf, stell dich nicht so an.
Ist es nicht auch dann Kunst wiederum?
Ist es dann wieder Kunst?
Also ich finde erstmal, das ist ein sehr spannendes Kunstwerk.
Es wurde sehr viel ausgestellt, sie war selber nicht da.
Es wurden ein paar Sachen, wurden aber wieder reenacted. Nämlich auch ihr sehr spannendes Kunstwerk. Es wurde sehr viel ausgestellt, sie war selber nicht da. Es wurden ein paar Sachen, wurden aber wieder reenacted, nämlich auch ihr sehr bekanntes Kunstwerk, was direkt am Anfang war. Und zwar stehen zwei nackte Menschen sich gegenüber in der Tür. Und das ist sozusagen der Eingang zu der Ausstellung. Sie stehen sich gegenüber in der Tür, also zu versperren den Tür.
Der Eingang zur Ausstellung ist eine schmale Tür, man stellt sich eine normale Zimmertür vor
und da drin stehen ein Mann und eine Frau nackt sich gegenüber.
Und noch ein bisschen Abstand zum Türrahmen heißt, man muss sich da durchzwängen.
Und das ist der Anfang der Ausstellung. Man muss sich durchzwängen. Jetzt muss man dazu sagen… Aber was sind das für Menschen? Also sind das dann Mitarbeiter von der Künstlerin oder so Assistenten, so diese Sekundärkünstler oder was sind das für Leute? Also früher war sie das selber mit ihrem damaligen Lebensgefährten. Inzwischen sind das einfach SchauspielerInnen. Und das ist natürlich dann insofern schon blöd, früher stand sie halt immer da. Immer wenn die Ausstellung offen war, stand sie da mit ihrem Mann und man musste durch. Jetzt, als wir dann in Zürich waren, in dem Kunsthaus, stand dann vorher auf der Website, wann das Kunstwerk da ist. Und natürlich bucht man sich den Slot, wenn die da sind, klar. Das macht es aber schon weird, weil dann trifft man schon die Entscheidung. Weißt du, was ich meine? Das ist schon seltsam. Und man denkt da die ganze Zeit drüber nach. Und das ist auf eine Art wirklich brillant. Und man geht da durch und natürlich will man gucken, wie andere durchgehen. Und es ist sehr spannend, weil es fällt schon auf, Männer gucken häufig zur Frau, Frauen gucken häufig eher zum Mann. Das fällt schon auf. Und alle sind danach, tun sehr nonchalant. Also das ist ja lustig, wenn man sich in den Eingangsbereich stellt und man guckt wie Leute da durchlaufen war dann so ein Mann der so ach ach bin ich hier also der ganze Weg man läuft wirklich zehn Minuten durch diese Schlange und dann ist man dann da und so also du weißt dass du richtig bist aber alle haben diesen ach bin ich hier richtig gucken sich immer so ein bisschen um und ja, und überspielen komplett, dass sie gerade durch zwei Nackte sich gedrängt haben. Sehr, sehr spannend. Aber gibt's dann auch so Leute, die dann so, das wieder so unterlaufen wollen und dann mit denen reden oder so oder dann sagen, geht aus dem Weg, also die dann sozusagen so ein bisschen, nicht trollen, aber so ein bisschen schlauer sein wollen als das Kunstwerk oder? Ja, haben wir nicht gesehen. Und ich glaube, das, ja, wird man auch nicht machen mit den Leuten, die jetzt schon in der dritten Iteration hast. Aber es ist schon spannend. Ich habe auch immer was passiert, wenn man dazwischen stehen bleibt. Und dann steht man zwischen den beiden und so. Und ab wann ist es sozusagen, wird es problematisch. Da ist auch jemand vom Museum, der da schon auch aufpasst. Da steht schon jemand. Und dann, wann würde der einschreiten? Der mit so einem grossen Q-Tip, wie so einem Zweihand-Q-Tip, den ich dann einfach so durchdrücken würde, einfach weiter. Das ist einfach wie so eine Kunstfabrik, so eine Abfertigung. Ja, mit so einem grossen Daumen, wo man sie rein drückt rein. Das fand ich sehr interessant. Also ein sehr spannendes Kunstwerk. Und ja, durchgezwängt, ich mich durchgezwängt. Man ist wie Luftholen. Ist schon sehr merkwürdig, Fremden, Nackten so nah ausgesetzt zu sein. Man ist wie so Luftholen, man geht rein und tut auch wirklich so, als wäre es gerade nicht passiert. Wäre es angenehmer, wenn man auch selber nackt wäre oder ist es komisch, wenn der eine komplett angenehm ist? Du hast ja Anorak im Winter, Anorak die Mütze mit dem Bommel obendrauf, die Skischuhe, du bist ja in kompletter Monturschneehose. Ja und dann vor allem am Ende der Ausstellung habe ich dann hinter mir jemanden entdeckt, der war schon recht korpulent. Und da habe ich gedacht, also auffallend korpulent, und da habe ich gesagt, der muss die weggeschoben. Also der muss die wirklich weggeschoben haben und das ist dann nochmal eine andere Herausforderung. Das mag ich dann wiederum nicht, dass es sozusagen auch Körpertypen bestraft. Weil das sollte Kunst nicht. Weiß ich nicht. Für mich der schlimmste mögliche Job, gar nicht wegen der Nacktheit jetzt so, das sowas selber zu machen, sondern einfach, weil ich auch einfach meiner Blase nicht vertraue. Ich habe wirklich ein geringes Vertrauen in meine Blase.
Und mein erster Gedanke wäre, was ist, wenn ich nach zwei Minuten aufs Klo muss?
Gar nicht jetzt so, wo man sich immer denkt, ja, wie macht das ein Formel-1-Fahrer eine Stunde und dann so bla,
sondern meine Angst ist so, nach zwei Minuten, er sagt, okay, alles klar, ihr beiden.
Dann wünsche ich euch viel Spaß, habt einen schönen Tag und dann sehen wir uns heute Abend um 18 Uhr. Alles klar? Gut. Jetzt muss ich aufs Klo. So. Ich glaube, bei mir im Kino, wenn ich im Kino, ich war auf dem Klo, der Film beginnt, ich setze mich hin, ich muss aufs Klo. Und ich glaube, das ist nicht, weil ich aufs Klo muss, sondern weil mein Kopf sagt, mein Kopf geht zum schlimmsten möglichen Szenario. Was das schlimmste mögliche, was jetzt passieren könnte, ich muss aufs Klo. Ich habe oft das Gefühl, dass ich nach dem Toilette gehen noch mehr aufs Klo muss. Aber ist es anatomisch möglich, dass die Blase nicht vollständig entleert wird oder ist es ein rein psychologisches Ding? Ja, ich erinnere mich an meine ersten damals, keine Ahnung, es gibt so eine Kinderuntersuchung, die ist so verpflichtend, ab, weiß ich nicht, so pubertär. Es war so, da musste ich mich zum ersten Mal ausziehen von einem Arzt und weiss das noch gut, weil das war, da ist man schon im Alter, wo einen das beschäftigt. Und in diesem Alter, da hat der Arzt wissen wollen, ob meine Blase komplett leer wird. Hat das auch untersucht irgendwie. Und seitdem ist es mir irgendwie so eingebrannt in meinem Kopf, fuck, die Blase könnte gegebenenfalls nicht ganz leer werden. Schrecklich, schreckliche Vorstellung. Weil es nervt mich eh, dieser Drang aufs Tod zu müssen, da ist man so, man ist plötzlich so ordinär, menschlich. Weißt du, was ich meine? Man geht so aus seinem Gedankenpalast zurück und muss dann kurz noch diese fleischliche, dieses fleischliche Müll wegbringen. Man guckt irgendeinen Film von einem Genie an oder so, oder man guckt sich, weiß ich nicht, eine krasse Doku an über jemanden und da muss man aufs Klo. Ja, das ist peinlich. Meine Nachbarn müssen aufs Klo. Und die schauen sich nicht so gute Dokus an wie ich. Weißt du, was ich meine? Das ist ja dieses Floating-Head-Prinzip. Dein Körper hält dich zurück. Sagst du auch häufig den Satz? Ja, absolut. Das ist ja im Prinzip auch eine Abhebung von allem anderen. Was ich alles schon nicht machen konnte in meinem Leben, einfach weil ich meiner Blase nicht vertraut habe, weil ich mir dachte, vielleicht hätte ich da, ich meine, vielleicht hättest du dich durch meinen nackten Leib zwängen müssen, dass ich da stand, ich hätte mich zum Casting angemeldet, ich gehe zu jedem Casting, egal für was, und dann bin ich da dabei und dann stehe ich da und dann kommst du vorbei und dann sage ich, kannst du mich kurz ablösen, Stefan? Stefan, kannst du mich kurz ablösen? Nein, ich wollte hier nicht hin. Ich wollte hier nie hin.
Ich muss ganz rennen, ich muss ganz rennen, ich muss ganz rennen.
Stefan, ganz kurz.
Ja, ich, na?
Wir haben einen ähnlichen Körpertyp.
Ich kann mich noch jetzt nicht aus.
Ja, aber bei dir ist das so ein Act, bei mir ist einfach Exhibitionismus.
Das ist ja für dich egal, ich bin auch kein Künstler.
Was?
Ich bin auch kein Künstler, das ist ja ...
Du hast gesagt, du bist Künstler!
Was heißt Künstler?
Leben ist eine Art von Kunst.
Ich glaub das jetzt nicht.
Stefan, das sehe ich aus, jetzt komm schnell.
Pssst, also jemand von nebenan.
Pssst, ja. Ja, okay, dann geh kurz. Zieh ich mich da so aus. Ja, die kam mit Bademänteln an. Ah. Tattoos erlaubt? Wir hatten keine Tattoos. Ich fand das ein sehr, sehr spannendes Kunstwerk. Ja. Die Idee war, sozusagen ein komplett anderes Gefühl zu haben, also man lässt so die weltliche Blabla-Welt, normalirdisches Kram hinter sich und betritt diese Kunstwelt. Und es ist als Reinwaschung gedacht. Weiß ich es nicht, aber es hat auf jeden Fall was gemacht. Ich glaube dieses, ich schaue Dokus an, ist auch eine gute Art,
Themen anzusprechen, die vielleicht
so ein bisschen unangenehm sind,
anzusprechen. Möchtest du was ansprechen?
Nö, gar nicht.
Nee, ich habe nur jetzt letztens
so eine Doku gesehen über Leute, die sich irgendwie schon
seit Jahren kennen und dann
aber irgendwie der eine den anderen total hintergeht
und mit dem ganzen Geld dann so durchbrennt.
Das ist so eine Geschichte von so zwei
Typen, die haben sich kennengelernt,
die haben dann so ein Projekt zusammen gemacht
Vielen Dank. irgendwie der eine den anderen total hintergeht und mit dem ganzen Geld dann so durchbrennt. Das ist so eine Geschichte von so zwei Typen, die haben sich kennengelernt, die haben dann so ein Projekt zusammen gemacht und haben dann auch angefangen, irgendwann da ein bisschen Geld zu verdienen. Und es war dann so, dass einer davon dann plötzlich unerwartet mit dem kompletten Geld dann durchgebrannt ist und den anderen so komplett geghostet hat. Eine mega spannende Story. Da kommt man ja auch so ein bisschen ins Nachdenken. Aber es ist ja eine echte Geschichte, es ist eine echte Geschichte. Und dann denkt man, das ist ja schon so, ja krass, das kann ja jederzeit passieren. Aber ich bin mir sicher, der Typ hatte gute Gründe dazu, der es gemacht hat. Ne, tatsächlich nur reiner Egoismus. Und der ist dann in die Seychellen ausgewandert.
Ah, wo da?
Da gibt es so eine Insel im Osten, wo das Steuerlich total... Ah, Marivi. Genau, ja, tatsächlich. Und da gibt es einfach steuerlich supergute Konditionen und da kannst du untertauchen. Und da gibt es dann anscheinend auch so ganze Organisationen, die dann irgendwie dir so neuen Namen geben und so und dann, das ist schon krass, ja.
Ja, krass.
Soll ich dir die mal schicken, Doku, oder?
Ja.
Ja, schick doch mal.
Kann ja jederzeit passieren.
Ich habe eine neue E-Mail-Adresse.
Oh, wirklich? Okay.
Ja.
Sebastian Tetzlaff. Sebastian Tetzlaff at gmail.com.
Der klingt ja echt neu, der Name. Hm? Der scheint dir noch nicht so flüssig von den Lippen zu gehen. Sebastian Tetzlaff. Sebastian Tetzlaff at gmail.com. Der klingt ja recht neu, der Name. Der scheint dir noch nicht so flüssig von den Lippen zu gehen. Sebastian Tetzlaff. Okay, und ist das eine Gag-Email-Adresse für Reddit oder was, wo du deine eigenen Posts abvoten kannst? Ja. Okay. Also mein Tipp für euch, falls es sensible Themen gibt, versucht es über eine Doku anzusprechen. Ich finde das eine richtig clevere Idee. Niemand hinterfragt, warum man Dokus anschaut. Ich habe letztens eine Doku über die Hitlerjugend angeschaut und so. Und es ist immer so, ja, okay. Genau wie ja über die Mondlandung. Bei True Crime Dokus ist ja auch gerade so, je brutaler, desto besser. Je mehr Twists and Turns und noch mehr Tote, desto besser. Und dann haben die den, also wenn die jemandem erzählen, ich habe gestern die Sogeguckt und die war so geil. Und dann sagt der, ja, und am Ende haben die dann noch die Wände aufgemacht von dieser Wohnung, die er gewohnt hat. Und da waren tausend Tote. Da wäre doch keine Reaktion so, was guckst du da? Genau, sondern die Reaktion wäre, krass, was der Link oder wo läuft die? Und dann hört man ja, dass es ja vor allem eine weibliche Sache gerade ist. Sehr viele Frauen gucken, lieben True-Crime-Dokus. Und unsere natürliche Reaktion darauf ist, ah, spannend irgendwie, cooler Fun-Fact, niemand sagt, was ist mit denen los? Und das finde ich schon spannend, deswegen hast du glaube ich komplett recht. Ja, du hinterfragst nichts. Du kannst mich zu den absurdesten Themen Dokus anschauen. Ich habe das in der Doku gesehen über so einen Menschen, der in einem anderen Menschen drin gewohnt hat. Also der ist da sozusagen als kleines Kind ist er in den anderen Menschen rein operiert worden und hat dann, er wusste das nicht, sondern ist dann quasi sein ganzes Leben in dem Körper des anderen wie so ein Parasit. Ja, das war keine Doku, das war Poor Things. Was, wirklich? Du hast den Film Poor Things geschaut. Fuck, ich dachte, der ist so realistisch. Das ist keine Doku. Ich habe gegen so eine Space-Doku gesehen, über so Space Exploration von jemandem, einem Jungen, der hat dann gelernt, dass er magische Kräfte hat, also so ahnt man so. Genau, das war so eine Space-Doku über, ein Planet sah so aus wie Mars, glaube ich, da waren dann Menschheit so irgendwie so Alkohol-Aliens-Kreaturen, ja, weiss ich jetzt nicht, das ist irgendwie eine Doku. Du meinst Star Wars? Ja, genau, so hieß die Doku. Das ist keine Doku, das ist ein Film.
Da habe ich so eine Doku geguckt über so einen neuen Polizeiroboter aus den USA.
Okay, ja.
Das fand ich auch richtig cool, diese Doku.
Wäre auch sehr spannend gemacht so.
Robocop?
Ja, du kennst alle Dokus. Du kennst alle Dokus. Ja, ich schade auch viele Dokus. Du kennst alle Dokus. Stefan. Ich habe letztens eine Doku über Dokus geschaut, wie die produziert werden, die Dokus. Und dann meinten die, dass den Dokus ja auch oft viel im Nachhinein nochmal nachgeschossen werden muss. Ich habe sie auf Englisch geschaut. Und dann... Das ist übrigens,
daran merkt man wirklich, wenn man Dokus nacherzählt
und plötzlich driftet man in so ein
hartes Denglisch ab, dann weiss man
vermutlich. Ja, weiss man genau so. Du hast es nicht
genug durchdrungen, um das mit eigenen Worten
zu erzählen, sondern du musst, ja dann war dann
dieser Investigator, der war dann so irgendwie
mit seiner Taskforce. Ja, Information
Bias ist ja schon ein Thing.
Ja. Ach ja, ich würde auch gerne mal eine Doku machen. Twist and Turns und damit rechnet man gar nicht. Twist and Turns und Plot-Twists. Wir nehmen gerade in Hamburg auf und ich bin gerade zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben beim Schwarzwein erwischt worden. Aber nicht im dicken, oder? Nicht im dicken, weissen Zug, nicht in der dicken Made. Also in der dicken Möhre habe ich mir natürlich ein Ticket gekauft. Das Ticket gelöst, ja. Und ich, normalerweise, wir wissen nicht genau, wann wir fertig sind und oft habe ich ein Flexticket. Und ich fahre heute hin und zurück und manchmal ein Flex-Ticket und da ist auch dann oft das City-Ticket mit drin, also man kann hier rumfahren. Ich Sparnase, habe zweimal den Supersparpreis genommen heute und wusste das nicht mehr und bin in der Bahn eine Fahrt, die 1,68 Euro gekostet hätte, Kurzstrecker Hamburg HVV, liebe Grüße. Und ich wurde auch noch nie kontrolliert hier, außer jetzt das eine Mal, wo ich kein Ticket hatte. Und da höre ich nur hinter mir, Tickets bitte. Und ich habe da auch selbstverständlich mein Bahnticket rausgeholt, gesagt, ja hier bitte. Und er so, nee, super Sparpreis. Was mit so einem ernsten Gesicht auch, nee, ist der super duper Sparpreis für Sparfüchse. Ja, ich nehme auch zu sehr für mich das Super betonen, das ist der super Sparpreis. Das ist der super duper Pfennigfuchser Sparpreis, da ist kein Ticket mit dabei. Das ist der, ich drehe jeden Cent um, Sparpreis. Seit wann heißen die so? So, und dann wirklich die ganze Tortur. So, ja, stehen sie auf, sie haben kein gültiges Ticket, hier raus. Dann muss ich mit dem raus, Ausweis geben. So, und dann das ganze Gespräch geschiftet, weil ich war, ich war, glaube ich, sehr nett für einen Schwarzfahrer. Also ich war sehr kooperativ, wir haben uns sehr gut verstanden. Und dann hat er gesehen, wir kommen aus der gleichen Ecke und er ist nach Hamburg gezogen und wir haben uns
super verstanden. Wir haben uns,
das war so toll, wir haben wirklich, das war so
lang, wir haben eine Viertelstunde oder so gelabert,
irgendwann hat er mir das Du angeboten, wir waren schon ein bisschen
älter, wir haben gelabert, dann vom
Familien, Elternhaus erzählt, bla bla bla, alles
und dann hat er mir die Darksten Family Sachen
erzählt, das war richtig,
richtig gebondet und
ganz toll verstanden und ich dachte mir, ja, hier geht's um 1,68 Euro. Also ist ja allen klar. Und es war wirklich sehr nett. Und dann, ah, da wohnst du, ich gehe in die Strasse und sowas. Und dann sagt er, ja, hier und gib mir dann dieses, dieses Knöllchen, 60 Euro. Und ich dachte mir, war das gerade alles für nichts? Ich habe deine ganze Familiengeschichte mir angehört. Ja, ja, ich war freundlich zu dir. Ich war freundlich für nichts. Ein zwischenmenschlicher Moment ohne Gegenleistung. 60 Euro, den Maximalpreis? Ja, da ist nicht mal fünf Euro drin für, wir haben früher in der gleichen Grundschule in der Ecke geraucht. Und ich dachte, das kann doch nicht dein Ernst sein, Dieter. Das kann doch gerade wirklich nicht dein Ernst sein. Ganz nett verabschiedet, trotzdem, lieben Grüße, tollen Tag gewünscht, aber ich hätte mir das wahrscheinlich nicht alles angehört.
Du musst, bevor du dir näher kommst, sagen, worum geht's hier. Also eine Art Ehevertrag. Dass du wirklich sagst, so eine Art Mitmenschenvertrag. Was ist das gerade hier? Interaktion, professionelle Natur, freundliche Natur, Schnittmengen, wo? So, das stimmt. Ich hatte tatsächlich noch einen gegenteiligen Effekt mal. Ich wurde auch vor langer, langer, langer Zeit auch mal beim Schwarzfahren erwischt.
War es völlige Absicht?
Völlige Absicht, komplett. Es war wirklich immer diese zwei Stationen, irgendwie dieses Ehrenfeldding da so. Da gab es immer so zwei Stationen. Da wohne ich, sag nicht Ehrenfeldding da. Dieses Ehrenfeld, die Rotzecke da, dieses Kaffding da. Zum Glück bin ich da raus, ey. Und das war wirklich immer so zwei Stationen oder so und dann immer schwarz gefahren. Und dann wurde ich erwischt und ich war dann so, ah ja, okay, Entschuldigung, ja, nur zwei Stationen und sorry. Und dann meinte er so, ach, du bist echt sympathisch. Was? Ich dachte bis gerade, es gibt gar keine Optionen. Doch, anscheinend, aber ich glaube, die Option ist halt nur alles oder nichts. Ich glaube, du kannst nicht sagen, ah bist ein netter Kerl, dann war 38. Sag mal, weil dann denkst du, das war jetzt 22 Euro wert. Diese Interaktion war 22 Euro wert. Wirklich? Aber es ist so irre, weil wir haben uns so gut verstanden. Und dann sind seine anderen Kollegen dann schon so weggegangen. Er hat gesagt, ja, ja, war er noch mit mir da, noch erzählt von seiner Familie, und dann drückte er mir am Ende die 60 Euro rein. Und dann habe ich am Anfang den Fehler gemacht und habe gesagt, mein Arbeitgeber hat mir die Tickets gebucht. Oh, fuck, habe ich nicht gesehen, der hat wohl mit kein, ich kann nicht sagen, ich habe, ich war da super, super Prämien im Sparfuchs, ich habe das Flex-Ticket, weil ich habe so ein Flex-Ticket, habe ich gesagt, er sagt, ja, verstehe ich komplett, kannst du mit deinem Arbeitgeber drüber sprechen? Ich dachte mir die ganze Zeit, ich bin ein Arbeitgeber, ich bin ein Arbeitgeber. Und dann hat er gesagt so, das muss ich mit Herrn Tietze besprechen. Dann hat er gesagt, ja, ich schreibe das jetzt mal auf, das zahlt dein Arbeitgeber bestimmt. Und ich dachte die ganze Zeit, ja, ich bin ein Arbeitgeber, ich muss das bezahlen, ich muss das bezahlen. Naja, also das war ein bisschen ernüchternd, wo ich dachte, haben wir das Gespräch gänzlich anders wahrgenommen oder fandst du mich cool? Also ich respektiere das auch. Ja, es gibt Menschen in ihrem privaten Umfeld und ihrer Funktion. Das ist wie Green Mile. Du kannst den Gefangenen nett finden, aber am Ende musst du den trotzdem hinrichten. Die Doku habe ich auch gesehen. Das ist ein Film. Glaubst du, in der Doku spielt Tom Hanks mit oder was? Ja, der spielt in vielen Dokus mit. Stefan,, wir müssen nochmal durch deine DVD-Sammlung gehen und nochmal alles durchgucken. Ja. Was du fälschlicherweise für den zweiten Teil gehalten hast, ich meine, jeder kennt es, du gehst ins Kino, denkst dir, geil, zweiter Teil Flucht der Karibik und dann ist es nochmal der erste Teil und dann denkst dir, hä, dann schaust du den ersten Teil nochmal an, obwohl du dachtest, der zweite Teil.
Das ist mir so oft passiert.
Übrigens keine Antwort von Klaus Badelt, Badelt, Klaus Badelt.
Klaus Badelt.
Und jetzt habe ich wieder neulich gehört, dass der Hans Zimmer vielleicht doch mehr geschrieben hat. Hallo Praxis, Doktor Surkamp. Ja, guten Tag. Kann ich für Sonntag einen Termin machen? Ich habe gehört, Sie haben da auch offen. Woher wissen Sie das? Jetzt hören Sie mir mal ganz genau zu. Ich will zwei K das? Ich will zwei Kornschrippen und ich will drei Vital-Knöpfchen. Alles klar. Okay? Ja, kommen Sie einfach durch den Hinteraus. Egal, egal wann ich komme, Sie legen das zurück. Der Code ist 0991 für die Hintereingang.
Es ist immer vor, deine Praxis hat den Klingelton.
Du kannst nie wieder Flut der Riebig anschauen.
Ich glaube, jede Melodie kann verhunzt werden durch Henniklingelton.
Das ist der klassische Fehler, mein Lieblingslied, Henniklingelton, kannst du nicht mehr hören. Und so natürlich auch, ich glaube, du könntest wirklich diesen Sound in der regulären Fußgeneration abspielen, dieses und du hast Leute, die zusammenbrechen, einfach körperlich, einfach in sich zusammen kollabieren, die jahrelang gearbeitet haben. Das hätte Klaus beide nicht komponiert. Ja, mein Klingelton ist jetzt inzwischen sehr uncool, der Wama Kula ist... Der russische Orgasmus von Jamba? Ist der... Du ziehst es auch durch, ne? Ich zieh es auch durch. Du hast einmal 16 Euro dafür ausgegeben fürs Jahresabo. Ja, und jetzt bleibe ich dabei. Ich bin ein Supersparfuchs. Ne, ist die Melodie von Curb. Oh ja, gut. Und das ist sehr lustig, weil zwischendurch hat man mal einen komischen Moment, da ruft jemanden an und du hast halt diesen, da ist das ganz, ganz toll, aber natürlich jetzt inzwischen wieder ein bisschen inflationär benutzt, ist ein Meme und ich reite auf so einer doofen popkulturellen Welle, das will man natürlich nicht. Aber wie hast du das jetzt mitbekommen, Hans Zimmer hat mehr doch mitkomponiert? Gibt es einen andauernden Streit? Ich weiss es nicht. Es gab ja mal die Zeit, da stand er als Komponist auf dem Film, dann gab es eine Zeit, da stand Klaus Badelt und Hans Zimmer auf der Platte. Und jetzt steht nur noch Klaus Badelt bei Spotify. Aha. Und deswegen dachte ich, da gab es wohl einen Rechtsstreit, der wurde gelegt. Klaus Badelt war damals der Mitarbeiter von ihm, irgendwie bei, wie hießen die, Remote Productions oder sowas, war diese Hans SimZimmers-LA-Firma. Und er war ein vielbeschäftlicher Mann, hat viele Projekte angenommen und ich dachte, ah, Klaus Beider hat wahrscheinlich das übernommen, intern dann, so als Prakti oder was auch immer, einen guten Job gemacht. Und er war halt unter dem Dach Hans Zimmer dann aufgeführt und irgendwann hat er sich dann so rausgeklagt oder was auch immer. Das war meine Variante, an die ich immer geglaubt habe, meine Realität. Das habe ich aber in einem Podcast gehört, ich weiß nicht mehr wo, dass es wohl so war, dass Hans Zimmer einen Grossteil der Musik geschrieben hat, aber vertraglich noch bei Last Samurai gearbeitet hat und da im Vertrag stand, das ist ja so, man darf nicht an anderen Projekten zeitgleich arbeiten. Das ist ja klar. Jetzt hat ja offensichtlich Last Samurai den wesentlich schlechteren Soundtrack. Würdest du jetzt sagen, die Macher von The Last Samurai, aka Tom Cruise, sind im Recht, dagegen Fluch der Karibik zu klagen, weil sie den schlechteren Soundtrack bekommen haben?
Könnte Tom Cruise einklagen,
dass der Fluch der Karibik Soundtrack für La Samurai benutzt wird und andersrum? Dann hättest du bei Fluch der Karibik diese ganzen asiatischen Japan-Klänge. Ja, warum nicht? Und bei La Samurai hast du dann Wie ginge das also, du jetzt als juristischer Amateur, aber kannst du eine Einschätzung liefern? Mein Name ist Christian Sammecke von WBS Legal in Köln. Seid ihr auch von dieser Datenleck betroffen? Dann schau doch mal einfach unten auf dem QR-Code, da haben wir schon vielen geholfen. Wir haben vom Podcast-Ofer die Frage gestellt, ob Lars Samurai sich sozusagen den Soundtrack von Flutter Karibik beklauen darf. Das ist nicht so. Abgelehnt! Weil Hans Zimmer steht da nicht drauf. Ergo, Hans Zimmer hat keinen Vertragsbruch begangen, weil Klaus Bardelt steht ja als alleiniger Komponist drauf. Argo hat auch einen schlechten Song. Hat fünf Ausgaben. Ergo ist unser Partner für diese Folge. Argo ist auch ein guter Film. Aber es stimmt schon, es ist natürlich schwierig. Man kann es nicht vorher sagen, welche Musik gut ist und nicht. Wurde nicht jetzt auch so ein neues Stück entdeckt? Ich glaube von Mozart. Von Mozart. Und dann glaube ich, gab es jetzt die erste Vorführung dieses neuen Stücks von Mozart und der Pianist setzt sich ans Piano und spielt Und alle so Und alle Zahnärzte schauen sich so an, so In diesem riesigen Konzertsaal über mehrere Dutzend Konzertreihen hinweg. Die Oper, die wiederentdeckt wurde von Mozart, Karius und Bactus. Mit der ersten Arie Aronal und Elmex, in dem Duett. Und das wirft Aronal, Aronal, Aronal, Aronal, Elmex, Elmeal, Arun bisschen, die ein bisschen. Die Redzitter, die nerven, man denkt, weg, weg, mehr Musik, mehr Musik. Wie fandst du es? Also es ist ja ein interessantes Experiment, finde ich. Es ist ja auch oft so, dass der Künstler das Werk überschattet und man Stücke, die von Mozart sind, automatisch als gut wahrnimmt, weil man den Namen im Kopf hat. Ja, wie die Beatles, ja auch noch so einen Hidden Track. Ja, das meine ich gar nicht. Und jetzt hast du ja bei Mozart endlich mal die Möglichkeit, ein Stück zu hören und davor schon zu wissen, okay, das ist Mozart. Ah ja, cool, weil du alle anderen Tracks von Mozart kennst. Stopp! Hat man hier nicht ein riesiges Versäumnis versäumt, hätte man nicht das Stück einfach als, guten Tag, mein Name ist Sigurd Bragaticec, ich bin ein neuer Komponist, ich habe ein neues Stück geschrieben, wollt ihr das hören? Ah ja, love it, love it! Und dann spielst du das Stück von Mozart und alle so, ah, schrecklich, was für ein Amateur! Ja, super. Und dann so, äh, tatsächlich bin ich... Nein, nein, nein. Reisst sich die Maske vom Kopf. Ja, und es ist Dino Kanz, der bei Verstehen Sie Spaß Bladicek erfunden hat und in Wahrheit ist es fucking Wolfgang. Aber seine, Moment, was ist denn seine Augen? Seine Augäpfel wurden ersetzt durch Mozartkugeln. Das wäre mal ein Experiment gewesen. Und dann erschießt er uns mit so einer Mozartkugel, aka. Zu Pistazienkugeln geschossen. Aber hier hat man was versäumt, finde ich ganz klar. Super Idee. Man sollte immer, wenn ein neues Gemälde oder so gefunden wird von einem Künstler, das erstmal aushängen als einfach Paul. Einfach Paul. Einfach von Paul. Neues Gemälde, es ist eigentlich von Van Gogh. Jetzt muss man aber auch sagen, es wurde ja wahrscheinlich in der Zeit geschrieben, da war Mozart schon weltbekannt. Das heißt, um die authentische Reaktion zu bekommen, müsste man ja dann trotzdem eigentlich sagen, dass es Mozart ist. Aber du willst einfach herausfinden. Ich will herausfinden, ob man das neutral objektiv bewerten kann, ohne dass der Name das beeinflusst. Warum macht man das nicht? Warum hat man diese Option verworfen? Oder noch anders, es ist da gar nicht von Mozart. Es ist eigentlich von Strachmaninov und alle sagen, ah, herrlich, Amadeus hat sich mal wieder überboten. Und er sagt, und Guido Kanz nimmt es ab. Genau, Guido Kanz reißt die Maske ab. Aber Paladitschek. Es ist Paladitschek, Paladitschow. Und der sagt, nein, das habe ich komponiert. Und dann alle, ja, dann ist es schlecht. Dann ist es schlecht. Könnte man nicht jetzt, könnte nicht Österreich das jetzt hinschicken zum ESC, weil es ja jetzt erst rausgekommen ist.
Weil es ja komponiert wurde, ja.
Nee, nee, weil es jetzt erst rausgekommen ist. Das Release-Date ist wichtig für den ESC.
Und, oder, könnte man den Grammys jetzt Mozart nominieren?
Das ist keine, aber was heißt rauskommen? Ist es denn veröffentlicht im Sinne von...
Ja, es wurde gefunden, jetzt wurde es aufgenommen und ausgegeben. Es wurde aufgenommen und ausgegeben. Ja, sowas. Words, words, words. We don't know. Okay, finde ich aber spannend. Also Grammys, fucking Amadeus ist nochmal dabei, Amadeus gegen Kesha, das will ich sehen. Ja, Charlie XCX ist nominiert und das Wolferl. Okay. Spannend. Dennoch als Wolf. Das finde ich aber super. Ja, Lil Wolf. Lil Wolf. Aber ESC finde ich eine richtig gute Idee. Wenn das geht, ich weiß nicht, ob wir da Experten da haben, die sich mit dem ESC auskennen. Also, ich will ja schon sagen, ich kenne mich schon aus. Nein, nein, ich meine, ich meine, es sind Experten, die da wirklich auch was zu sagen haben in der Branche. Du bist ja in der Musikbranche schon länger raus, muss man sagen. Komplett raus. Nachdem die letzten 18 Alben hart gefloppt sind, nicht mal in die Charts eingestiegen sind, warum hast du nach 15 weitergemacht, warum hast du nach 16 weitergemacht, warum hast du nach 17 Flops weitergemacht, aber jetzt bist du schon so ein bisschen raus, du bist jetzt eher in der Literaturecke angekommen mit deinen Oh, ich war neulich tatsächlich in der Oper mit unserem lieben Podcast-Kollegen und Editoren Rainer Nigrelli, der hat auch How to Sell Drugs geschnitten, Editorus, hat viel fürs Neomagazin damals geschnitten, auch gute Arbeit, kennen wir gut. Und mit Rainer war ich in der Oper, wir haben Elektra gesehen und es ist passiert, was du mal gesagt hast, soll es geben. Nämlich Q&As nach der Vorstellung direkt. Aha, mit den Akteuren. Mit den Darstellern. Und es stand vorher schon drauf, Nachbesprechung. Und wir schon so, was ist das, wir wollen es sehen, how awesome is that. Geil. Also sind wir danach zu dieser Nachbesprechung gegangen und dann saß da die Hauptdarstellerin, die Bösewichtfrau und der Dirigent und der Dramaturg. Dampfine? Dramaturg. Elektra gegen Dampfine, ist ja so ein bisschen diese Starlight Express-Geschichte eigentlich. Ja, Klytemnestra saß da, Elektra saß da, der Dramaturg und der Dirigent. Und dann saßen die da und das Publikum... Orchester weg. Einfach weg. Orchester in die KVB, Tschüss. Das finde ich ein bisschen hart. Weg! Und dieser, sollen wir noch bleiben fürs Q&A? Nee. Ach, gar nicht. Sch, weg hätte zum Fagott, weil ich, falls Fragen zum Fagott kommen, dachte ich. So ein grosses Oropax, also weg. Ja, und dann kam, aber dann hätte ich nur Fragen zum Fagott gestellt und dann so gucken die so, ähm, ach so, ja, die Annette ist jetzt schon, ähm, kann der Frank nochmal kommen? Äh, können die ersten Fagotte nochmal kommen? So, und dann sitzen die in der KVB mit dem Livestream und lächeln. Fahrkarten bitte. Haben sie nicht. Müssen ihr Fagott abgeben, weil es genau 60 Euro Gegenwert hat. Wie viel soll so ein Fagott kosten? Am I right? Und was wurden dann für Fragen gestellt? Das ist das Problem. Ich nehme, das Publikum war relativ massiv, nehme ich mal an, oder?
Massiv.
Ja, also wie viele Leiber waren da vorhanden?
Also am Ende der Nachbesprechung sagen wir 50 nur noch.
Hm?
Was?
Was ist das für eine Reaktion?
Am Ende der Nachbesprechung?
Moment, aber wie groß ist das Publikum?
Bei der Oper?
Weiß ich nicht, 1000?
Tausi?
Und dann bleiben 50?
Ja, oder 60. Okay, dann geht's. Dann ist okay. Sehr wenig, ja. Aber das ist doch klar. Also wenn es sind Nachbesprechungen. Fühl mich kurz durch. Also das Stück ist zu Ende, tosender Applaus, alle verbeugen sich. Genau. Wie geht's dann weiter? Also bleiben die dann auf der Bühne, während alle gehen, oder treten die danach nochmal extra aus?
Alle mussten auch raus, dann mussten wir nochmal zurück.
Also zumindest haben wir jetzt so gemacht, vielleicht können wir mal sitzen bleiben, weiß ich nicht.
Jedenfalls kamen die dann und durften mal Fragen stellen.
Und wir haben ein bisschen debattiert, ob wir da hingehen wollen, weil es ist schon einfach sehr unangenehm.
Da habe ich mir das vorgestellt, was für Fragen gestellt werden.
Und so eine Opa ist ja lang, ne?
Und es war sehr lang und die sind sehr fertig und wir dachten, und man muss auch sagen, dass das Problem ist, hat auch alles überschattet, das ist das ganze, die Kölner Oper ist ja noch nicht fertig, das heißt, wir waren in dieser Interimslösung, das Staatenhaus in Deutz, das war so ein Messehaus, ein ehemaliger Nazi-Riesen-Prunkbau, nein, kein Prunkbau, Messehalle, aber von außen. Das Gegenteil. Eigentlich wollte ich das Gegenteil sagen. Nutzbau. Genau. Und in der Mitte haben die einfach so ein Opern, was auch immer, Bühne reingebaut. Und das Orchester spielt neben der Bühne. Das ist alles ein bisschen merkwürdig, die haben dafür mehr Platz, aber es kommt so von links der Sound und das ist alles ein bisschen merkwürdig. Und da alle Fragen reden sich nur darum. Wann wird die Oper fertig? Warum, wie ist es von der Seite zu dirigieren? Wie finden Sie das hier denn schön? Ist das für Sie toll? Einer hat nur gesagt, ich finde das übrigens alles richtig scheiße, dass wir hier sind. Keine Aussagen beim Q&A. Aber wie ist es denn, von der Seite zu dirigieren? Hast du die Antwort noch im Kopf? Ja, also der war vor allem recht begeistert, weil Richard Strauss, Riesenorchester, hätte gar keinen Platz im Orchestergraben in einem normalen Opernhaus. Das ist ganz toll, da konnten die ja mit dem voll, vollblauen 110-Mann-Orchester, Frauorchester, links neben der Bühnene spielen und es ist ein bisschen scheißegal. Die Akustik ist
natürlich sehr belämmert, sehr schlecht,
aber
ja, das ist auch schon
alles gesagt. Also der kann die Leute,
der kann denen keinen Einsatz geben,
aber da stehen Kameras und dann wird es ohne
Latenz, wird es ein
Konterfei auf die Bühne
projiziert, das ist ja beim Style Express genauso.
Passte schon, meinte der. Und das war für mich das Thema auch gegessen. Aber fürs Publikum nicht. Nein, nein, nein. Okay, es wurde hitzig. Aber war es so ein, okay, hat noch jemand Fragen? Nee, keiner mehr? Ende? Oder? Ich will wissen, es gibt zwei Arten von Q&As. Die, die enden, obwohl es noch Fragen gab. Und die, die so dahin plätschern und dann so, gibt es noch Fragen? Nein? Das Spannende war... Ist das ein Reflex, ist das eine Hand? Genau. Ah, sie kratzen sich. Nee, hier vorne? Wo es so eine Auktion wird. Nee, das ist ein Gips. 200 mehr? Das ist ein Gips, nee, das ist ein Gips, sie haben auch ein Gips. 250, nee, gut, 250. Zwei Gipse, ah, sie strecken sich, sie strecken sich, okay, alles da. Keine Frage. das Problem war, die ganze Runde hat geschmissen, also der MC der Runde war der Dramaturg. Okay. Und dann kam es zu dem Moment, dass so, es war klar, es kommt keine Frage mehr, perfektes Schlusswort, grosser Lacher, Alarm geklatscht und er sagt, hat noch jemand eine Frage? Ach, Dramaturg. Und ich dachte mir so, du bist Dramaturg. Du, du bist Dramaturg, es muss dir doch gehen, um Ende ... Das ist ... Sprich wir mit deinem Job. Dein Job ist Dramaturg. Du wirst, wann Schluss ist. Ja, du weißt es nicht. Das ist dein Job. Ja. Was ist das für ein nerviger Epilog. Ach geil. Alles, alles gesagt. Perfektes Ende. Und ein Dramaturg gesagt, hat noch jemand eine Frage und niemand und ein Schweigen für eine halbe Minute. Toll. Ich meine, wenn bei Romeo und Julia am Ende alle tot ineinander, Arm in Arm, nebeneinander liegen, sagt dann noch irgendjemand, hat noch jemand eine Frage, können wir noch mal über das Buffet reden? Nein, dann ist Schluss, nicht an. Und er, und dann dachte ich mir, jetzt hätte ich gerne eine Nachbesprechung von der Nachbesprechung. So, wie haben Sie diesen Moment erlebt gerade? Es war doch offensichtlich Schluss. Auch gar keine Frage zur Inszenierung, gar keine Frage. Nur so, wie ist es, die Glutimnest? Ah, einer hat gefragt, es ist ja so eine sehr attonal, also sehr dissonante Oper. Wie ist das denn für die Sängerinnen und Sänger? Das ist ja bestimmt schwierig, das so zu lernen. Und dann hat die Regierin gesagt, ja, das sind alles Profis.. Und dann war so, ja, okay, cool. Aber ich fand die Frage auch böse. Aber generell eine coole Idee und hat mir gesagt, man häufiger dahingehend, das ist eine coole kulturelle Veranstaltung, es macht Spaß. Ich finde das aber eine super Idee und wahrscheinlich, also ich kenne den Mann nicht, aber ich denke, dass ich das analysieren kann. Richard Strauss oder Dramaturgen? Zu Richard Strauss habe ich ein gutes Verhältnis, den Dramaturgen noch nie gehört. Dass natürlich solange keine Fragen zur Inszenierung kamen, fragt der dann weiter nach Fragen. Also sehr klar, bis er nicht seinen Moment hatte, muss er weiter fragen. Der Dramaturg denkt sich nicht die Inszenierung aus. Der Dramaturg ist der Typ vom Haus, der mit dem Regisseur der Regisseurin arbeitet. Ich stelle mir das vor, keine Ahnung, Rian Johnson übernimmt den Star Wars, da gibt es ja diesen Autorenraum, was auch immer, Leute, die kennen die Lore, und er geht rein und sagt, können Lichtfetter auch Kreise sein? Also technisch gesehen ist es eigentlich möglich, denn der Cyberkristall ist durchaus in der Lage, also ein Kreise, wenn wir das Energiefeld zu finden. Kann der Millennium-Falken auch rückwärts fliegen? Also technisch gesehen sind die Booster dazu in der Lage zu einem kurzen Zeitpunkt. Genau, und da gibt es ja diesen Raum, ob man zugreifen kann. Und ich glaube, im Opernsinne ist das der Dramaturg. Jemand, der so sagt, ja, kann man schon so sehen, kann man schon machen. So bei Wagner, der Ring ist niebelungen, kann der Ring auch ein Kind sein? Ja, also das hättest du gesehen, dass es den Urtext jetzt nicht unbedingt gesehen darf, eigentlich Kind, aber das halbe Kristall eines Rings kann schon durch ein Kind sein. Ja, ja, sowas. Okay, hatte ich ein ganz anderes Bild. Ich hab mir da eher so einen schalbewehrten Typen dargestellt, der gesagt hat, naja, die Rampe ist ja eine Metapher für die Weiblichkeit. Und wenn Glüthel-Nestra die Rampe herunterrutscht, ist es ja auch eine Art Entfrauung. Und dann hat der Dramaturg, der hat vor allem die Einführung gemacht, die Werkseinführung davor. Die haben wir auch schon besucht. Und da hat er uns gesagt, was passiert am Ende. Ihr habt euch ja das ganze Juniortüte gegeben, die komplette Tüte. Er hat erzählt, was passiert. Er hat gesagt, das wird ganz spannend, dann im dritten Akt ganz toll unsere Inszenierung gelöst. Und du so, lalalalalalalala! Weil es nicht gesponert werden. Er hat den ganzen dritten Akt gestört. Weil ich dachte, wann kommen wir jetzt die Messer? Arschloch. Fuck, Arschloch. Aber Nachbesprechung und Nachbesprechung sind eine gute Idee. Und das dann einfach, das ist eigentlich, das wäre mein Kunstwerk. Ich mache ein Kunstwerk, ich mache eine Inszenierung, also so wie Abramowitsch, Abramowitsch, mache ich so eine Inszenierung, ich gehe nackt auf die Bühne und klatsche zweimal laut in die Hände, ich sage Hu, Hu! So, und dann Klatschen, Hu, Hu, Klatschen. Genau, und dann gibt es Q&A. Du hast einen Bademantel an, oder bist du immer noch ein? Nee, ich ziehe den Bademantel an fürs Q&A. Dann setze ich mich hin, dann gibt's ein Q&A. So, zehn Minuten. Echtes Q&A? Echtes Q&A, echtes Q&A mit mir, so, was haben sie sich dabei gedacht, okay, alles klar. Dann gehe ich von der Bühne, trete nochmal auf, bitte alle Leute, die eine Frage gestellt haben auf die Bühne, und dann gibt's Q&A zweiter Ordnung. Ihr spielt das Q&A nach? Nee, die Leute können jetzt wieder Fragen stellen, aber auch an die Leute, die Fragen stellen, was haben sie sich bei der Frage gedacht, waren sie zufrieden mit der Antwort? Und dann wieder, wir gehen von der Bühne, die Next, alle kommen wieder auf die Bühne, so dass immer mehr Leute auf der Bühne sind und auch immer weniger im echten Publikum, die immer mehr Angst haben, dass sie jetzt eine Frage stellen müssen, der Druck steigt. Ich glaube, in der zweiten Runde wird schon keiner mehr eine Frage stellen, weil die Angst haben, dass sie auf die Bühne gezogen werden. Ja, aber dann... In Amerika wird es funktionieren. Okay, aber dann schweigen wir die zehn Minuten durch. Okay, wow. Weil es ist ein Riesentimer. Tok, Tok, Tok, Hu, Hu, Tok, Tok, Tok. Okay, wo kommt das jetzt her? So, das ist die Uhr, die die ganze Zeit tickt. Ja, hättest du am Anfang sagen können, Herr Dramaturg. Wenn jemand eine Frage hat, dann müssen wir die zehn Minuten durchmachen. So, jetzt brauche ich einen Raum und dann machen wir das. Sehr gut. Für den Klatschteil bin ich noch nackt und danach aber habe ich einen Bademantel an mit Bärchen. Wenn ihr einen Raum habt, sagt Bescheid. Generell auch wenn ihr in Hamburg einen Raum noch für Podcast aufnimmt,
schreibt einfach mal in die Kommentare rein,
dass ihr einen Raum bekommen.
Wir suchen vielleicht ein kleines Studio in
Hamburg. Lasst euch inspirieren diese Woche,
geht mal raus, geht ins Museum, geht in die Oper,
schreibt mal eine Oper,
fuck it, wir brauchen neue Opern, schreibt
mal ein Stück, das ihr dann als Mozart-Stück
verkauft. Wir wissen ja nicht, ob es ein Hoax war, liegt da alles noch im Rahmen, falls ihr den ESC leitet oder in einer Funktionärsfunktion leitet. Lasst euch die Chance nicht entgehen. Mozart for ESC now, Hashtag now. Versammelt euch alle unter dem Hashtag now. Okay. Versammelt euch alle unter dem Hashtag now. Und wir schaffen das. Mozart for ESC, Hashtag now. Wir kriegen das hin, Leute. Mozart zum ESC, dann holen wir uns die 15 Punkte, okay? Haut rein, check it up, check it up, bleibt steil, wicked bis nächste Woche, haut rein. Ich hebe schon ab. Was gut, baby? Mop, chick it up, bleib steil, wicket bis nächstes Wochen, hau rein, was gut,
wem ab, chickity ciao, it's a world-born production!